let me begin by thanking c-span for the
opportunity to be interviewing know me
prince who was the author of it takes a
pillage behind the bailouts bonuses and
backroom deals from Washington to Wall
Street when I was in the house for 16
years I served on the Financial Services
Committee so I have some familiarity
with this issue and needless to say I
have been actively involved in it last
three years in the Senate know me thank
you very much for being with us today
well thank you very much and thank you
for taking the time to be here as well
today senator let's begin with a little
bit of background about you where were
you born and what happened in your life
to end up to have you end up on on Wall
Street and write the books that you've
written well i was born in upstate New
York in in Poughkeepsie right outside of
vassar college where my father had at
one point been a professor and then he
was I'm working in research at IBM there
was very much an IBM town at the time
and we were very much as a mathematical
type of family a lot of work with
numbers from from a very very young age
and I ultimately want to go into a state
school to suny purchase a little closer
to New York City getting closer to wall
straight to some extent where i studied
mathematics and i minored in music but
my father said math is really the way to
get a decent living and you know find a
job and as it turned out that was that
was true because ultimately that was
what was being hired on Wall Street at
the time a lot of math and engineering
and computer science were really the
degrees that the street was looking for
and so what I really just wanted to do
is move to New York as you do when you
graduate college and I wound up getting
my first job at chase manhattan bank
before it was part of JPMorgan Chase
when I graduated actually before I
graduated even I was I was 19 I sort of
did a transition chief yes I wasn't it i
started they are doing a lot of analysis
and sort of computer work and numerical
work on what was wrong with you why but
others are partying and having a great
time they filled up
I was way too serious it was the oldest
child in the family and I think that
might have had something to do with it
that sort of sense of responsibility and
financial independence and everything
else I think I somehow wound up over
there and I figured that was only going
to be there for a year or two and sort
of work in musical theater or something
else in New York instead and as it
turned out I wound up staying there a
very long time through a number of
different firms and I think it just
became just easy to some extent with all
of the hardness that comes with wall
street and within wall street firms you
did make enough money to pay rent in New
York City and everything else nothing
like the kinds of sums that are being
made today but certainly enough to to
live on your own let me ask you this I
mean you write your book in a sense as
being in the belly of the beast so to
speak you were there so what impact on
your views on your life views about Wall
Street occurred as a result of your
working for Goldman Sachs how many years
did you work for goldman sachs I was the
goldman sachs for two years it was the
end of my career on Wall Street I
actually ejected myself from Wall Street
after having been at Goldman Sachs &
Bear Stearns worked in as well and
embarrass turns as well I was over in
London actually for Bear Stearns around
and analytics group there for seven
years so that was really the crux of a
lot of the work I was doing on Wall
Street and internationally and then I
came to the golden so what impacted your
experience on Wall Street have on your
views what did you like you're on the
inside most of us are not on the inside
yeah one of the things you know on the
inside and you learn on the inside is
there is such a tremendously competitive
environment which there aren't a lot of
other places with it but in Wall Street
it's almost like you come in every
single day and the higher you move up in
a firm the more this is the case every
single day trying to figure out how much
credit you can take for a particular
trade if you can beat someone on another
desk or in another area of the firm you
actually race to the offices of senior
management in order to be able to tell
them what you did take part in a certain
deal or a transaction and very much
becomes it's this immediate type of an
environment where if you don't do that
you don't succeed and if you're someone
who who
to try and succeed you sort of get
involved in this game and I ultimately
found that very distasteful and really
quite empty but but the environment is
very much like that it's very intense
from a gamesmanship in a power sort of
play as well as it's really like
military strategy almost every day going
in literally from whose name you put on
an email first to whose office you go
into first to who you tell about a
certain trade before someone else knows
what's the United States Congress but
that's another song but but let me ask
you let me ask you a question I think
that is on the minds of millions of
Americans right now we are in the most
serious economic decline since the Great
Depression if you add up the number of
people who are unemployed underemployed
and given up looking for work seventeen
percent of the american adult workforce
isn't that position it is a disaster
people have lost their homes they've
lost their savings they lost their
pensions all because in my view at least
of the greed of the people on Wall
Street now one of the first question I
want to ask you is some people say well
nobody could have predicted this my god
it just came out of the blue it was just
amazing totally unpredictable how do you
respond to that it was absolutely
predictable for a lot of reasons one is
that that mentality in the street the
reason this crisis happened was because
there was a desire to find products and
to create assets within Wall Street that
made money and they don't really care it
doesn't matter to Wall Street firms what
those assets are it turned out that they
created assets out of a small amount of
subprime loans and when I say a small
amount I look at it like it's an
upside-down pyramid where at the bottom
point you have subprime loans and 1.4
trillion of those were issued during
2002 to 2007 but what Wall Street does
is it takes them and it creates new
securities this whole other band of
securities and from those it can make
fees it can make Trading Commission's in
a lot of other prophets they made 300
billion dollars just on creating
securities out of these loans not on
even training them back and forth just
on the sheer creation of these
securities during those same years and
then what they do is they take those
securities they
borrow against them to create new ones
and to merge and to acquire and to trade
and to speculate so it all goes up or
that's why this whole thing fell down it
wasn't that the subprime loans got wrong
it was that all of the Securities and
trading on top of them toppled over you
know what I think most people kind of
scratched ahead and when they went to
school and we learned about economics
you see somebody starts a business and
maybe they maybe they sell automobiles
and maybe they sell clocks maybe they
sell shoes maybe they manufacture these
things so here's my really tough
question here what the hell do they do
unwashed it what do they make what do
they produce well they produce acids
that only have value because they choose
to say that they have value there is no
shiranai like with your life of my kids
lives it absolutely doesn't it and
that's a really good analysis of the
street that wall street's exists in
particularly investment banks and the
most speculative components of banks
exist purely to create to engineer
that's what they talk its engineering
asset that's not engineering a train
track it's not engineering a building
its engineering something that only has
value because they say it does and and
it it gets its value from from that I
have a quote in my book which is great
from the senior partner at Goldman Sachs
who left the firm to actually go to
Morgan Stanley and it was quite senior
there I said it's one of the only
finances one of the only arts that's
basically our science is created
predicated on the creation of absolutely
nothing and it's only by pushing that
none nothing for something throughout
the system because people continue to
buy it that this continues to churn you
create these sort of upside down
pyramids of risk and assets that don't
truly have intrinsic value so at a time
when our manufacturing capability is
declining when we've lost millions of
good manufacturing jobs our
infrastructure is in major disrepair we
desperately need scientists to help us
deal with illnesses etc etc we're seeing
some of the best minds in the country
going into a sphere of activity which
produces virtually nothing that is
useful to the ordinary person
it is not useful to the ordinary person
it is purely the amount of profit if you
look at a company like Goldman Sachs the
top to your investment firm they pay
almost fifty percent of their profits
out and bonuses in another in any type
of production company or even retail
company the amount of money that's paid
in terms of compensation is maybe twenty
percent or twenty two percent so all of
that extra fluff all of that extra
profit that's really just about moving
transactions are really moving money
back and forth goes directly into these
extravagant bonuses and extravagant
compensation structures it doesn't go
out anymore doesn't even pretend to go
out anywhere it stays right there and it
looks to me like we're developing two
separate worlds and I can't remember the
figure I think was like something like
forty percent of the profits in America
are now being made on Wall Street right
is rather an extraordinary number it's
an extraordinary force in New York City
it's an even greater proportion of what
what revenue comes into the city and
it's an obscene number because it's
really not predicated on the creation of
anything we're still talking about
assets that pretend to have value and
then are rated to have value there's
there's all these other agencies that
work with Wall Street like the rating
agencies like SP and like Moody's and
they come in they basically stamp value
by deciding that these assets are worth
a certain amount or that they have a
certain quality attached to them they
call it Triple A and if you call
something triple-a it sounds really good
and investors buy and pension funds by
it and States by it and individuals hear
about it from their local bankers and
and so basically this infiltrates the
entire system I remember I'm a member of
the Budget Committee now and we had Hank
Paulson and a couple of years ago and I
said mr. Paulson back in my state of
Vermont around this country the middle
class is on a whole lot of trouble
people are really struggling people
losing their jobs their income is going
down as a growing gap between the very
rich and everybody else what's your
sense of the economy and he said all
economy is doing really good and year
after year and this is really astounding
and a bit aggravating year after you we
heard from the Bush administration that
from their perspective the economy was
doing great now explain to me how they
could believe the economy was
great when the middle class was
collapsing and we were getting closer
and closer and closer to the edge of a
major global financial crisis because
for them it was great and that's the
problem no 2006 was the record year of
bonuses on Wall Street 2006 now between
2006 and 2007 foreclosures in this
country just between march two thousand
six in march two thousand seven
foreclosures increased by forty seven
percent so it isn't like there wasn't
information coming in that would
indicate there was a tremendous problem
brewing and it's not like someone like
treasury secretary at the time Hank
Paulson who had been a CEO of Goldman
Sachs and understands numbers could not
have seen that but the fact is Goldman
and other firms were paying out record
bonuses that year because they were
manufacturing as things were getting
weaker and they knew this they were
manufacturing an even greater amount of
these assets because I sort of wanted to
turn it all in and sort of take profits
as much as they could as soon as they
could because they actually knew things
weren't going to continue to stay all
straight knew there was a less trading
going on in some of these which was why
they were created more these ultimately
these toxic assets because Wall Street
knew that the game might be up and so
they pay themselves well they created
these assets and pulse and should have
known this the Fed should have known
this because on the other side of all of
this was declining loans was increasing
foreclosures increasing defaults this
was real data you know I got to tell you
from my end of the street so to speak
sitting in the Congress and in hearing
these guys talk it's like they were
living in another world where you had
Bernanke himself who now chairman of the
Fed who for a while was a major economic
advisor to the president I didn't hear
anything coming from these guys to say
wait a second we got to do something
because we don't act we may have the
collapse of finance of the United States
and around the world where were they at
this point well that's it I don't think
they were looking at this data or if
they were they were choosing to ignore
it or to act optimistic because that
served a political agenda because you
don't you don't want to be the party in
power when the crisis happened so if you
can sort of push along and sort of will
it to not happen and sort of give this
and this
I look at it from the outside but give
an optimistic spin on things even with
negative data coming in you can sort of
push it on to really the next guy or the
next administration or the next fellow
was he almost got out he almost got it
is but you want if it happened just in
the beginning of 2009 it would have
changed but the reality was all this
stuff was brewing talk about for a
moment this whole business of
deregulation my understanding is that
during a ten-year period Wall Street
spent about five billion dollars
pressuring Congress through lobbying
efforts through campaign contributions
to deregulated away with glass-steagall
etc etc what impact that all of that
deregulation allowing these merchants to
take place have on the ensuing the
financial collapse well the repeal of
glass-steagall was really the catalyst
for what ultimately became a decade
later the collapse and and actually what
even became a few years later some enron
and worldcom and the other scandals that
we like to forget about because they
were all predicated on the idea of
merging and acquiring and banking
institutions becoming not just bigger
which they were doing there was a record
merger spree as well leading into the
repeal of glass-steagall which which
happened almost a year ago today on
November 12 19 99 was when
glass-steagall was repealed I voted
against that i bought it against that
let me let me back to record clear well
now i did you vote against it i think
you also said that all the things that
would happen to consumers to mergers all
of that a big a bit facetious but it did
happen i mean all of the warning signs
unfortunately came into fruition and the
reason for that is that when banks
merged and when concentration changes so
that the more powerful ones have more
deposits and control more loans and
control more actual capital they can
churn it they can trade it they can
speculate with it because it is there
and so that's what ultimately caused the
crisis is that you had extra capital and
extra access to consumers that you could
use real money in real loans and real
assets and turn them into something that
ultimately became a crisis I'm gonna
move you a little bit and ask you a
question here's an interesting question
during those years when I was a member
of the Financial Services Committee
every year Alan Greenspan would come out
and after everybody rolled out the red
carpet and God had walked into the
chamber and you cannot believe I believe
me there was and and Greenspan gave
forth his libertarian philosophy that
the best thing that we can possibly do
is the way with all government
regulation and we allow these guys on
will she do anything they want somehow
this wealth Aegon to all the right
things that it's going to create great
wealth for all the American some of us
of course did not believe it but
unfortunately a majority of the people
believed in now here's my political
question of you which is interesting and
I think maybe says a lot about our
political system the president who
originally appointed Alan Greenspan was
the first president Bush and he was
reappointed now and the first president
Bush was considered to be maybe a
center-right type of politician he was
reappointed and you know Greenspan is an
extreme right-wing guy by a liberal
democrat named Bill Clinton then you had
some years later mr. Bernanke is
appointed by kind of a right-wing
Republican named george w bush and a
liberal democrat wants to reappoint him
what's going on people I generally
believe that there's a difference in
opinion between a first Bush in the
Clinton and a second Bush and an Obama
how does this happen well well first of
all there there hasn't been really a
change in any of the regulations that
come onto the financial world between
any any of those two administration
changes unfortunately we hope there will
be back that well let me back them up
she's raising a very interesting point
maybe I speak as an independent here
who's not a democrat or republican but
what you're essentially saying that
while there are differences obviously
every day between democrats and
republicans are these kind of key
financial issues about how we deal with
wall street and who's head of the Fed
does not seem to be a heck of a lot of
differences by kind of what you're
suggesting it seems like one of the
least partisan things in in washington
because if you look at just the sheer
regulations that were passed the
continuation of Fed Chairman de under
under the changes from Republican to
Democrat both times there isn't a
tremendous amount of difference in fact
there's more financial deregulation done
under Clinton than there was underneath
and first secretary of the Treasury then
secretary already yes who happened to
have also been a co-ceo at one point of
Goldman Sachs which is a whole other
issue this revolving door from Wall
Street and it so happens from Goldman
Sachs into the presidency whether or not
there is a democrat or republican
presentation was also it Paulson who was
when i was there he would he was he was
my boss yes he was head of Goldman Sachs
became Treasury secretary he was a
Republican under Bush to who was the
Republican but Bob Rubin of course was a
Democrat under Clinton who is a Democrat
but they were both for the same
deregulation he could have almost
interchanged them at any point in time
was already gone the same result it's
growing Tim Geithner where was Tim in
the midst of all this well Tim of course
well if we talk about where he was in
terms of the bell and everything else he
was head of the New York Fed which had a
very tight relationship with Wall Street
it is through in New York feathered
first of all most the bailout money came
but also historically that has had the
tightest relationship and a revolving
board or between the board of the New
York Fed and leaders from Wall Street
right now for example Jamie Dimon has a
senior position on the board of the New
York Fed he runs a large large bank
JPMorgan Chase he seceded Sandy Weill
who was running Citigroup which was you
know so this is constant revolving door
and so if you're running of your
president of the New York Fed you have
perhaps the closer relationship to Wall
Street than almost the chairman of the
Fed you know then even a Ben Bernanke
would happen why run the fake jump into
the fence let me let me mention
something you last year I had been
ranked he came before the Budget
Committee and this is during the whole
bailout process and so forth and as you
know and well I want to get into this at
some length at the very least we know
that the Fed lent out over 2 trillion
dollars and zero interest loans to
financial institutions so I said through
a chairman ben ikea said you know can
you tell the american people who got the
money its you're putting their money at
risk
most of us would like to know you know
some degree of transfer we got the money
and he said it was pretty amazing he
said not going to tell you two trillion
dollars of money and you're not going to
tell the American people ah by the time
that day was over we had introduced
legislation to make them tell us and but
how talk a little bit about that how can
a head of the Fed say with a straight
face I'm not going to tell the American
people with two trillion dollars of
their money at risk has gone yeah no it
was astonishing because I think at the
same moment or a few minutes later he
said it would actually be
counterproductive right to tell people I
remember the word counterproductive as a
how do you possibly get to that term and
I guess the reasoning besides the fact
there's a whole lot of banks who don't
want that information disclosed because
that would indicate how weak they
actually truly are even with the veil
out and with the subsidies from the
federal government and I think Bernanke
was basically using that face and trying
to somehow justify it by saying well
people new people actually knew how weak
their banks might be we would have this
catastrophic run on the banks it would
be breadlines 1933 all over again in the
world would totally collapse as we know
it and I think that whether he believes
that or not because I I personally think
that had we disclose this information
from the get-go from before the bailout
became as expensive as it became because
banks didn't know what each other hell
no one trusted anyone and that's why
credit tightened up and we actually had
full disclosure books back then I've
assets back then of what the Fed might
have been looking at back then we could
have avoided spending a whole lot of
money in this bailout but I think by the
time he got to that moment he was so
entrenched in the idea that if anyone
knows what actually went on it would
create and would it would create a lot
of anger but that I think was probably
his actual worry but he's what he acted
as if his worry was is that it would
create a run no that's exactly what he
did say but I think and by the way we
took that concept of the need for
transparency at the fed to the floor of
the Senate during the budget discussion
we want in a bipartisan vote because I
think it's very hard the average member
of the Senate
or the average American to say excuse me
you're putting two trillion dollars of
my money at risk and you're not telling
me who got it maybe we need a 1-800
number everybody in American get zero
interest loans and you don't have what
do you think exactly if I wouldn't get
zero interest loans we have a very
different merica but I'll tell you one
thing just on the back of that the New
York Fed actually is extending more
money than and had more open plans to
the banking system than the Fed fig
we're talking about the two trillion on
the feds book ultimately there was about
six trillion worth of facilities created
much of which went through the New York
Fed's book and they don't necessarily
aggregate them all so there's a lot of
other stuff that's not even near being
looked at who knows about this stuff you
know some of it is it's it's
quasi-public not not what collateral has
been posted and what banks have received
how much money that we are trying you
were trying to get to the bottom of that
information but when those facilities
were open when when they were created it
wasn't like there was a big media press
release but there is information that it
can kind of see through the digging
through the web sites and I did that I'm
and you can do it you can write a book
most of us probably know you can't do it
normally there's nowhere you can go on
fed website or the Treasury website to
say yeah what did you spend where did
you spend it how much is it worth now
when is it coming back there there is no
report that exists like that I know let
me ask you I'm going to put you on the
spot you ready all right based on his
record is head of the New York Fed and
now well let me get the tube Ananke do
you think President Obama poured forth
Bernanke to be reappointed to be head of
the Fed you think that was a good
decision I think that like you made a
lot of mistakes during this this this
whole crisis leading up to it in terms
of not looking at the information that
other people could have looked at and
that there were economist telling him
about but more than that more than that
the Fed has the ability to reject
mergers the Fed has the ability to deny
applications for banks like Goldman
Sachs that our investment banks and
Morgan Stanley to become bank holding
companies which makes them more publicly
accessible to the Fed in terms of
receiving funds of receiving any sort of
subsidies or perks from the Fed it's
it's the feds job
to be prudent about that and when Ben
Bernanke was in that seat he didn't say
for a moment we shouldn't have a merger
between Merrill Lynch and bank of
america he didn't say we shouldn't have
a merger between wells fargo wachovia he
didn't say why are we backing Bear
Stearns as assets in order to have them
merge into JPMorgan Chase he didn't say
any of that he didn't say wait a minute
goldman sachs you know what you can't
become a bank because you have too much
risk and we don't want the government's
money to back your risky he was in the
position to do that that was one of his
jobs and he didn't do that so I believe
by not doing that he's actually shoved a
really big second coming of the crisis
may be delayed a little bit but but
created a much less stable landscape
than we even had before last year's
crisis so you're not one of those folks
who say thank God because of that
decisive action in the bailout man I
we're over the hump now good times are
coming you don't accept that right now
there are some good times coming for
some banks because their federal capital
that they can use to go back into taking
risky physicians and trading and their
stock is up and their profits are up and
their bonuses are up but in actuality
there's more risk and there's more
consolidation and there's more power
amongst a fewer group of banks than
there was before the crisis so was there
a crisis averted I think it was delayed
that that's the way I look at it I think
there are other decisions that could
have been made last fall they wouldn't
have involved putting trillions of
dollars of public capital behind that
banking system without changing
dramatically the landscape of that
backing of that banking system as we
speak President Obama has indicated that
those financial institutions that were
bailed out he's going to cut back very
substantially on the kind of CEO
compensation but the other financial
institutions like Goldman Sachs they're
running as quickly as they can back to
before the crisis tell me about cuts be
if you like I'll do a group of people
who caused this terrible crisis and
suffering for tens of millions of people
in this country after getting bailed out
by the taxpayers of this country go back
to huge compensation packages and
bonuses go back to exactly where they
came from how do they do that they feel
incredibly ridiculously and tight
to doing that they go back to their
offices you know great crisis averted
let's go and make money which they are
Goldman Sachs is on track to make 23
billion dollars in bonuses that year
that's a couple more a couple more
billion dollars than they made in the
year before the crisis they're actually
doing better than they were before and
it's it's really this this mentality of
what we do here is intense and it's
important and it's this moment and it's
this trade and it's this transaction and
what happens on the outside it's their
fault it's their fault for not being us
you know it's you know again as an
elected official people sometimes
criticized appropriately appropriately
people in Congress living in a inside
the beltway mentality not knowing what's
going on I could tell you that in my
Slater among all over this country there
is fury there is rage against these
people and apparently they're not
interested they don't care because
nothing has happened to them you know
the rage and in the righteous rage other
of the public doesn't affect what they
get paid and it hasn't affected how they
operate they said at their last
quarterly earnings limit they are going
to continue to do what they do they're
very open about it they're not even
trying to necessarily hide this
information on that note we're going to
take a break with noemi prince whose
excellent book it takes the pillage
explains i think to a lot of people what
has happened in the last year and what's
likely to happen in the future we'll be
back in a minute afterwards and several
other c-span programs are available for
download as podcasts more with no me
prends and senator bernie sanders in
just a moment book TV sunday three new
books by and about Sarah Palin including
a book signing with the former vice
presidential candidate and Alaskan
governor the weekly Standard's Matthew
continent on the persecution of Sarah
Palin and reporters Scott Conroy and
Shoshana Walsh on Sarah from Alaska
Steven Gillen details the transfer of
power following the Kennedy
assassination and LBJ's first hours as
president and the US financial crisis on
afterwards no me Prince for
managing director of Goldman Sachs on it
takes a pillage she's interviewed by
vermont senator bernie sanders find the
entire schedule online at book TV org
including our four day holiday book TV
weekend starting thanksgiving morning
afterwards with noemi prins and senator
bernie sanders continues we're
continuing our discussion with nami
prince who's the author of it takes a
village no me it seems to i think many
Americans that we're living in a in a
world deeply divided a nation deeply
divided you got a Wall Street up there
you when you use the phrase a sense of
entitlement these guys make hundreds of
millions a year occasionally a
billionaire you got hedge funds
operating they're doing that thing and
meanwhile you have the rest of the
country which has seen in many instances
really deep declines and people standard
of living increase in poverty people
losing their health insurance so you got
Wall Street what we call Main Street um
what's the connection between the two
why does Wall Street get bail down and
get richer while people on Main Street
lose their jobs and the health insurance
and get poor what's what's that about
how do we turn that around I think for
one thing Wall Street has a tighter
connection to certain people in
Washington and much more money to lobby
and everything else and so there's
there's a more there's more of a sense
of keeping what they have and getting
more there's no such thing as an ethical
wall street right now there's no such
thing as we're going to stop ourselves
from making as much money as we possibly
can because that is there let Mia trust
you just mention this thing which to me
is kind of astounding but that's the way
it is you would you might have thought
that the people on Wall Street who
caused this severe economic crisis
that's one of them one of these guys
might have gone on TV and said you know
Americans I'm really sorry i agree got
away from us and i know all of the
suffering with it we've caused I'm sorry
and we're going to change away I haven't
heard that no there's there's no
contrition there's no awareness there's
no connectivity to the rest of the
country because honestly the people that
really run these firms have almost no
contact
literally they don't have a lot of
contact with real individuals but the
result of the crisis that we all saw
last year in the bailout and just the
decision to open a lot of federal
funding and subsidies and guarantees and
cheap loans and everything to Wall
Street as if that would somehow trickle
down to the rest of Main Street it
almost had the opposite effect it kind
of it kind of fortified the standing
people in Wall Street and the banks that
survived to kind of continue to do when
they're doing I mean let me interrupt
you to say that what you said is exactly
true the lines I voter to come I should
be clear I voted against the ballot but
um the line was this is not a bailout
for Wall Street this is a bailout for
Main Street and working day and night to
save Main Street but you don't agree
with that assertion well not only did
not agree with it back fana's you didn't
but i also don't agree with any of the
numbers that we have shown that that
have legitimately indicated that this
hasn't been the case credit did not
loosen in fact when the bailout was when
tarp was passed and that was only one
component of the bailout in the
emergency economic stabilization act
there was a little teeny piece of that
act that also allowed the Fed to pay out
more interest on reserve money that the
banks were keeping with the Fed so while
the banks are getting money they're
actually incentivized to not do anything
with it while the Treasury secretary and
others are saying that this will somehow
loosen credit for the American people it
didn't credit is tighter now and as a
result unemployment is higher now
there's a direct correlation between
credit on the time a crazy credit and
you know if people sort of running up
but basically the idea of credit for
small businesses for medium businesses
for individuals because once those
companies can't make payroll they close
they fire people they don't have pot
they have nowhere else to go and and
also out of this crisis the smaller
banks are continuing to fail in sizable
numbers we've had 99 closures just this
year of smaller banks while the bigger
banks are getting all of this capital so
even in the banking system there's
there's a wider gap and those smaller
banks feed a lot of the smaller loans
and the smaller businesses in the
individual so there's total knock-on
effect knock down effect really of the
bottom part of the country that's why
foreclosures are now at a record quarter
again not last year this year at a
record quarter this year there's more
defaults this year there's more
delinquencies this year people are
struggling more
after the bell a year after the
intervention yes an unemployment
national an appoint was five point eight
percent preceding that period of the
crisis last fall and now it is almost
ten percent and that doesn't even clued
the fact that in most cities in urban
areas 139 different urban areas have
double-digit unemployment from 1515
before the crisis so not only has this
crisis not held Main Street is actually
hurt Main Street so the bailout has hurt
mainstream art arm what do we do uh what
do we do to create financial
institutions that are part of the United
States of America that don't live behind
a wall of greed and selfishness and
irresponsibility and illegal behavior
what do we do to have financial
institutions play a role in providing
credit so that entrepreneurs and
business people can create real goods
and services and create meaningful jobs
what would you suggest that we do well
first of all we have to look at the
money that was given to the system and
because we didn't put the government
didn't put any strings attached to it we
actually have to start to attach some
strings and say you know what you said
you needed this you said you were going
to loosen credit you didn't here's what
you actually need to do you need to take
a proportion of your capital and there's
all this discussion now and there should
be about banks having more capital so
that they can actually control their
risk so that government doesn't have to
come in and subsidize it but the same
time I think some of that should be
divided out and more capital should be
given to those small businesses and more
capital should be made available and
renegotiation should be much easier
what's happening now is that not only is
credit not loosen but if someone wants
to renegotiate a home that's about to be
foreclosed upon and renegotiate their
mortgage you can't get it you can't get
anyone on the phone the process is so
exhausting and so conversant and
documents get lost because there's just
no accountability along the way remember
these little loans became these many
assets and so up here you can't even
find where the actual deed was to a
property and I think you need to
basically take a look at that and make
institutions more accountable and
there's a good reason to do that now
because they are sitting on capital
funding there's almost more of a reason
now to come in and say okay look you had
yours now here's what you need to do
use the word accountability on Wall
Street that is a four-letter word they
don't like a condom really but but it
will never come openly there no Lloyd
Blankfein CEO of Goma he's not going to
like come to Washington be like you know
what we're paying out 23 billion in
bonuses this year I'm going to cut that
I'm going to just cut it down to 0 a
measly 15 billion and I'm going to give
the rest of that money into some fun
that's going to help small businesses or
some fun that's going to give credit or
advisors or pay for them to help people
renegotiate their mortgages I'm going to
do that because I feel bad it will never
happen oh and so it needs some how it
needs to be ledge and particularly
because they have had public assistance
almost it's almost more of Wall Street
given that has received so much more
from from standpoint of the federal
government even than it was before hand
um and I think one of the things as a
senator I hear a lot about people can
understand understand how they're
bailing out these financial institutions
and then they end up paying twenty five
or thirty percent interest rates on
their credit cards which in the old days
used to be considered usually but now is
just the cost of their done business in
its its it's the fees on credit cards
it's these arbitrary fees that get
slapped on checking accounts and in
savings accounts even in all sorts of
things because now it's really a
byproduct of glass-steagall appeal to
some extent to go back a little
explained for a moment I'm not sure all
of the US dollar glass-steagall was
about what the repeal meant okay well in
1929 we had a tremendous stock market
crash in the United States which was
followed by the Great Depression and in
1933 when FDR was the president when he
came in basically 1932 but in 1933 took
office in the first couple days what he
did was he closed the banks because it
was noted that it was the bank's fault
it wasn't like people spontaneously
stopped paying it was that credit
tightened even back then speculation was
rampant even back then products would be
were being created with nothing inside
of them back then the same sorts of
things were happen and that was because
banks could take the deposits of
consumers the deposits of the population
and borrow against them is called
leverage on Wall Street in order to
speculate
right and they did and so what
glass-steagall was about was saying you
know what you cannot have a financial
institution that both has the right in
the access to population deposits and
makes loans to the population and have
them use that Tibet and gamble and
speculate that that just doesn't make
any sense in particular the federal
government cannot possibly be able to
back all of that risk it does it's all
kind of a black box and so a glass
ticket is what it separated banks out it
said you know what if you want to be a
bank and you want to deal with customers
and you can get those deposits your
commercial bank you go over here we will
back you and the FDIC was created at the
same time in order to back the deposits
of consumers enough of individuals in
the United States investment banks you
know what you are on your own you can do
whatever you want well maybe not totally
whatever although that has wooden what
happened but you can speculate you can
trade you can do whatever but you know
you we don't have your back we're not
going to back that risk the taxpayers
are not going to bail you out when you
fail right and that was just so logical
and the FDIC won't be there to tabac you
or to ensure your debt which is kind of
what they're doing on with Goldman Sachs
and Morgan Stanley it just it just won't
happen because it makes no sense because
then we came to the 80s and the 90s
people like Alan Greenspan and Bob Rubin
proceeded to tell the Congress why that
was classic was just a terrible
destructive idea for 1995 for four years
before appeal I remember Robert Rubin
was talking about this notion that we
couldn't be competitive as a nation if
our banks weren't allowed to do whatever
it is they do that the 1933
glass-steagall act was antiquated it was
old it didn't work in today's modern
world of finance and you just can't
constrict these because we're going to
be at a loss actually the United States
will actually decline in sort of
financial supremacy if we are not going
to allow our banks to do what all the
other banks are doing so the Congress
against my vote repealed glass-steagall
what was the remediate result of that
the immediate result was a wave of
mergers there were merges that actually
preceded glass-steagall such a Citigroup
and travellers there was an idea where
insurance companies could be apart now
commercial banks and investment banks
could be a part of commercial banks and
everything started merging together so
there was a first wave of mergers that
happened right after glass-steagall and
lobbying that year actually went down
because laughing was up the year before
lobby money went down so that was that
was
small temporary respite on that but and
then what happened is there was more
consolidation for a decade of the
banking industry so that you went from a
situation where the top banks had twenty
percent of the assets and deposits to
now the top banks have fifty percent and
so you just you just continue to
concentrate the industry and concentrate
it with more risk added to it and now
you have these banks using deposits
again as capital to speculate and trade
just like they did back in the 20s and
that takes us to the issue of too big to
fail yeah and we're too big to fail
means is is that if a huge financial
institution goes under it's going to
take half the economy with it and then
dust the justification for having to
bail them out now it seemed to me and I
said this on the floor of the Senate
that if an institution is too big to
fail it seems to me that it's too big to
exist right are you but since the
bailout we have not seen a breakup of
these large institutions quite the
contrary I don't know Paul Volcker among
others has raised that issue what do you
think about this too big to fail what
should we be doing I think we should be
going back to the current glass-steagall
we should be separating these banks back
out again we shouldn't have gone from a
crisis into a situation where there are
now fewer banks controlling more assets
in the country which goes back to what
the Fed was doing in terms of blessing
those mergers so we have a situation
where we need to separate them out we
need to separate out again the consumer
deposits and loans and assets from the
speculative investment banking and
trading because what we have right now
not only are the banks the big banks
bigger JPMorgan used to be just full
just JPMorgan Chase which had a lot of
mergers in it to begin with with them
having achieved the acquisition of bear
stearns it adds a really risky
investment bank Washington Mutual it
adds a whole bunch of consumer deposits
so now it's just this bigger animal
floating on more risk and that risk was
what we saw in their profits last
quarter there again no secret about this
the only reason they made money less
quarters not because consumers are doing
better consumers continue to post losses
because they continue to hurt where they
made money was in trading so I think we
have to totally take that risk
of the government's responsibility to
back which means you have to break up
these banks so people want to speculate
they can go speculaas there on their own
but not gonna get bailed out by the
government and if banks want to make
loans to people real people we will back
them up is what you're saying and that
makes so much sense because you could
not only will you back them up you will
understand the risk you know exactly
what you're dealing with I don't think
there's a lot of people in Washington to
sit there and look at what a crayon an
actual credit derivative prospectus or a
transaction occur with them you don't
and it's complicated and I think I think
to some extent it's actually not as
complicated as it's made out to me but
it's certainly arcane and it to anyone
who's not you know in the trenches and
and that's why it gets that's why Wall
Street gets away with creating a lot of
the securities it creates it uses that
lack of understanding i think to its
benefit let me switch gear for a moment
I I think the average American after the
bailout during that period wanted to
understand how the crisis occurred who
was responsible for it and how we hold
those people accountable who's going to
jail who was apologizing we really
haven't seen a whole lot of that in fact
one of the issues that we fought for
i-44 was a real investigation well
pakora you explain to folks what / court
the core investigation was in 1932 well
in 1932 pakora who was the assistant DA
in New York basically was asked to
undergo an investigation of
predominantly the banks and by the
Senate Banking by the Senate Banking
Committee to basically look at how what
the practices of the banks that were
happening at that moment contributed to
the crash and contributed to the
depression and that was and and what he
found was this idea of speculating on
the back of nothing or on the core JP
Morgan and these other guys we're gonna
head he
and and and he basically really hammered
them to explain exactly what their
practices were and exactly how they
inflated value and exactly what they
used what what deposits or money they
used in order to do that and it was so
clear from that so clear that this was
something that was a direct contributor
of the crisis it wasn't that and
foreclosures were high than to
historically for that period but that
wasn't the crisis that was just a
manifestation of what Wall Street was
doing that the little individual home in
in Vermont or in Stockton California or
wherever the foreclosures on those are
very very difficult for the individuals
but they are not what brought the system
down brought the system down is all of
the speculation that the Wall Street
mostly investment banks created on the
back of those loans but the American
people really have not gotten that kind
of explanation of what happened they
haven't had the leading the guys who
caused this problem in front of the TV
cameras answering hard questions heavily
that and that's that's really a good
thing to do with some of these guys have
been in front of various committees
mostly talking about their bonuses and
there's a good thing and a bad thing
about that certainly the bonuses are
agreed just particularly now after the
crisis and with federal funding beneath
them but if we just focus on the bonuses
we lose sight of the practices that
actually contributed to the bonuses so
you need to do both it and I'll great
will be really nice if you even got
these people in front to say they were
sorry but I mean I but even in addition
to that I think the American people are
owed an explanation of what happened and
then the understanding that the Congress
is trying to make sure that this doesn't
happen again but what I think you're
implying is these guys are very moving
very aggressively to bring us back to
exactly where we were before the
financial collapse well absolutely
because one of the things that
contributed to them being allowed are
being able to create these assets out of
loans is that money was very cheap money
was very cheap under Greenspan actually
in 2001 in early 2002 as a result you
have more esoteric loans being given out
because banks are getting this money
cheap and they need to figure out how
they get more out of it so they extract
from subprime where they extracted by
creating an acid or they they find some
way to create money from nothing or
money from cheap money and now we have
the exact same situation rates are very
low and in particular banking system is
getting like 02 quarter of a percent
loans from the Fed so we're in a
recreation of that scenario just on a
much grander scale let me ask you
another question changing gear again a
little bit um there is growing I think
interest in the fed itself which as
you've indicated today is an enormously
important institution but a very
secretive institution you can argue that
certainly in particular moments Ben
Bernanke the chairman of the Fed is more
powerful than President Obama it
controls more money petroliana he's a
key controls the ability to create money
that is a very powerful ability talk a
little bit about the Fed how does
somebody like the chairman of the Fed
get all of this power what do we know
about the Fed should there be more
transparency in the fat night I have to
admit that I am the author of the Senate
bill which calls for a Jo audit of the
Fed to do all of these things a little
prejudiced and asking this question but
I think whether you're you know you're a
conservative your progressive as I am
people just kind of shake in their heads
that an institution with so much power
can operate in so much secrecy what do
you think and and also subsidized so
much of a private sector and n reside in
Washington and I think I think to a
large extent the Fed in this particular
situation is totally overstepped even
its mandate and even what it was
designed to do the Fed is supposed to
I'm a regular working day you know
control yeah are basically set interest
rate it's supposed to set something
called monetary policy it's supposed to
raise rates lower rates depending on
whether or not money is easy or harder
to flush into the general system be used
for curl it be used for businesses or
what have you and they do that it's also
supposed to oversee these commercial
banks it's supposed to make decisions as
to whether they are allowed to become
bigger if there are risks within them it
is actually supposed to go in and say
something the fact is it doesn't because
it has such a tight relationship with
Wall Street with the banking system that
it's almost
like telling on your brother or do you
have to know how many people there are
on the fed how these guys appointed well
there's there's 12 Federal Reserve
Bank's there their appointed basically
people are appointed through those banks
if for example the New York Fed sort of
appoints people from its back door which
is which is Wall Street and therefore
you have a board of the Fed which which
controls to some extent how this money
goes back to where they came from to one
extent last year stephen friedman who
was chairman of the board of the fed at
the the New York Fed where where Tim
Geithner was president was at the same
time on the board of directors at
Goldman Sachs so you're basically you've
got your foot on the place that you can
get money from and you've got the foot
in the door of the place that gets
benefits not an expression for that it's
called an enormous conflict of interest
is a tremendous come from day one the
Fed was a conflict of interest from from
day one particular the New York Fed and
I mean the relationship is that the New
York Fed is the most powerful of those
12 feds but from day one that's a
conflict there should not be members of
that board on the board who are in any
way related to the banks that receive
any kind of money from from the Fed
otherwise call it a bank let it be a
private bank but but don't let it have
access to the ability to create public
money now how do in your judgment these
guys with so much power playing
literally with trillions of dollars get
away without the kind of public scrutiny
I made the point you know that when
you're on the floor of the Senate you're
fighting for 28 million dollars there
could be a six hour debate oh you don't
need that money it's only fun meanwhile
very quietly these guys say oh well
we're going to provide trillions of
dollars in zero interest no discussion
nobody knows who gets it how do we
what's going on well I think to some
extent um and you're different but at
the time I think there was an idea of
well the economies is going out of
control it spiraling downward something
needs to be done and for some reason the
Fed will know what to do and so there
wasn't as much question there was so
much debate over the bailout over the
seven hundred billion dollars and there
wasn't any questioning at the time over
what's been going on on the fed's
balance sheet and I think to some extent
their needs
being and certainly the auditing bills
are the way to do that and extend
opening what they're doing to the public
is a way to do that there needs to be a
required accountability to Congress
because it's public money period how do
you live in a democratic society where
public officials are supposed to be held
accountable without what without any
kind of knowledge yeah it's it's it's
it's it's wrong I think I think what
we've seen out of this this scenario in
particular is that the Fed should not be
a sort of isolated private secretive
organization if it's going to be
involved in huge raising of public funds
in order to subsidize a private industry
it needs to publicly disclose what it's
doing it is bizarre that that so much
conversation is given over 28 million
dollar additions to help anything he
almost looks like a shell game that
we're going to have all these great
motors were here I'm your boss I mean
there are great debates really well on
the floor of the Senate about $100,000
earmark that goes on an hour after hour
after hour and then you get trillions of
dollars being lent out here with no
discussion whatsoever at one point the
amount of money that the Fed had on
offer to the banking industry was eight
trillion dollars now it's six it is six
trillion dollars worth of open
possibility i'm not saying every bank
has used all that we don't know but but
there is an open possibility of six
trillion dollars worth of money i mean
that's just it it's staggering it is
stagnant and then you also debate over
stimulus package or if extending
unemployment benefits are saying and the
numbers aren't even in the same zip code
all right let me we're rapidly running
out of time but this has been a
fascinating discussion and I'm glad
you're your father major major in
mathematics or something it sounds like
a use that bathroom very productive why
don't we conclude our discussion uh
where do you think the president and the
Congress should go what would you like
to see them do right now well first
thing I think they should have a real
debate over to this idea of too big to
fail I think by simply increasing
capital limits and having these too big
to fail banks be sort of watched better
it is not the way to go because you're
watching something you don't under
stand I think we need to break them up
reinstate glass-steagall make them
smaller you know and I think that will
have the added benefit of reducing risk
in the system because then we know we're
actually dealing with and then you can
control compensation which is created
out of the risk-taking and out of the
bonuses that come from those profits
because you're subdue in the risk in the
system and yes bankers won't make as
much money but that's okay no me we're
running out of time but I think the main
point that you have made maybe the one
point of many many very good employment
points is that we can't look at wall
street or something separate from the
middle class and working families of
this country that we can continue a
process for where these guys live in
their own world do not invest in
anything a productive value while the
middle class continues to shrink and
unemployment goes up that they've got to
play a different different kind of a
role exactly and we can't make it up to
them that's the key thing President
Obama's talking about raising small
business loan caps and that is good but
if the banks don't want to extend the
loans it doesn't matter that the caps
are higher so there has to be an
attachment there has to be an actual
legislative attachment to making this
behavior occur all right on that note
let me thank know me Prince for being
with us